now you see we have a parse JSON
function that takes a string of JSON in
and then we're going to parse it using
the JSON dot parse method that is
included and accessible in just about
any modern browser json dot parsed takes
this string weapon dot JSON in and will
return a javascript object representing
the json that it's parsed now once we've
done that what I want you to do is grab
a specific piece of data from that JSON
let's say you want to grab data from the
JavaScript object returned from JSON dot
parse and let's say you put that
javascript object into the variable
parsed now in order to grab the chain
gun sub object then you would simply say
parsed frames chaingun PNG like so and
then put it in the variable chain gun
let's say and let's take a look up above
at the structure what that would do is
it would walk down first minute frames
and then in the chain gun and what would
be stored in the chain gun variable
would then be this entire structure so
everything inside of chain gun dot PNG
now what I would like you to do is grab
the X data field inside sprites source
size of chain gun impact PNG and go
ahead and print that out to the console
chain gun impact a PNG isn't up in our
example JSON but the JSON that we'll be
running through this function does have
it